This large rectangle here is divided into four smaller rectangles.
I want to express the face of the big rectangle
and I will do it in two ways.
The first way is like a work of two two-
and then I want to express it as a three-member.
Let's think about it.
One way is to get the height
of this great rectangle from here to here.
We see that this distance is x.
Then from here to here is 2,
so the whole height is here
will be x + 2.
The height is x + 2, and what is the width?
Going from there to there, is x.
And then there is 3 there.
So the whole width is x + 3.
x + 3.
Thus I expressed the face of the whole rectangle
and it represents the work of two two members.
But now let's say it as triple.
To do that, we can divide the whole face
of the faces of all these smaller rectangles.
What is the face of this purple rectangle here?
Its height is x and its width is x,
so his face will be x ^ 2.
Let me write it - it's x ^ 2.
What is the face of this yellow rectangle?
Its height is x, the same as here,
and its width is 3,
so his face will be x 3 or 3x.
I have a face of 3h.
So this face is 3x.
If we collect the face of this whole thing, it will be plus 3x.
Therefore, this expression here is the person
of this purple area plus the face of this yellow area.
We can now move to this green area.
What will be the person here?
The height is 2, and the width is x,
so we multiply the height in width,
which is 2 x
and we just add it: plus 2x.
And finally this little gray box here.
Its height is 2, we see this there,
and its width is 3, we see it there.
So there will be a face 6.
2 at 3.
Therefore, plus 6.
And maybe you will say, "This is not a three-
here are four members. "
But maybe you notice that we can get together
these two members in the middle,
3x plus 2x.
If I have 3x and add to them 2x,
I will have 5x.
So the whole thing is simplified to
x 2 + 5x + 6.
These are two different ways of expressing the person.
Therefore they have to be equal and there is logic,
because if you multiply these two members and simplify,
you will get this three-member.
We can do this very quickly.
Multiply x in x ...
Actually let me do it with the same colors.
You multiply x by x and get x 2.
You multiply this by x 3 and you get 3x.
You multiply 2 by x and get 2x.
And then you multiply 2 by 3 and get 6.
We can say that this face model
creates a visual idea
what is the logic of multiplying the two members
the way we do it.
In other videos we talk about it as a
applying the distribution property twice,
but this gives a more visual idea
for the logic of things.